SCOR II can't get to those bonds to
rebound himself
Clarkson after the assist for the Angelo
Russell who founded in front of the
Laker game
fouling if you want to stay in games
Gallo seven out of eight marks it's the
gray outside it down it goes to the
bottom of the world you know Julie's
doesn't want to pick up that could feed
the Angela Russell finds Jordan Clarkson
takers shooting eight percent that dear
us in the basketball shows it down the
middle malaria nets and hence scores
with the left hand has been little feed
and got that time look at that Angelo
Russell assist to Larry Nance Jr who
lays it up with the left nice dive and
hustle but it's the Angelo that is what
the Laker fans they're accustomed to
seen out in transition some highlight
places the over the head pass and
negative plus minus and the bench had a
positive plus minus you don't see that
very much rock inside finds the to
Livingston was there
Russell we know he can do this he's a
very gifted passer but about the jump
stop of step in double figures twenty
out of the last twenty one so consistent
these stars on the dish but the Angelo
Russell I 14 if defended back
Kobe using that offhand scores and
that's his fifth point why he Angela
back enforce with the dribble
no luck yes sir as the Lakers cut into
this lead they trailed 9184 Senate be
just five years down the line when he
did that interview and I'll tell you man
I think we're but now we got to step our
game up he's coming for our job so I
just say he stinks and Russell finishes
on the other end he had tried to sneak a
throat instead it's a three on one for
the US team Rodney hood goes to town
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hallo
[Applause]
don't
but a step bounce but the Angela for the
dumb Lakers fans have not been able to
celebrate their team for so long Kobe
behind-the-back Russell between-the-legs
Rando
that's what we needed right before the
quarter ends talking about the stories
here in California tonight we'll hockey
assist for Kobe try to cajole Jersey so
kick it out nothing for the Lakers in
D'Angelo showing his ability to drive
and kick the corner injury in Portland I
shot the ball as well that injure you
talking Garnica
to a great start the two-for-two
including that one from behind New York
sometimes though you get so caught up in
find that try to feed the hot hand and
it takes you out of your offense a
little bit Julius Randle knocks down the
AG put it along three corner that's the
longest part of the three-point arc and
it seems like it's about a foot out of
his money
the past I'll give the time to D'Angelo
Russell and Mozgov eight on the shot
clock
[Music]
young with the corner three ball good
[Applause]
[Music]
get away
as coaching staff at this point they are
they have no concern about Ingram son
jumpshot transition then you might
underneath Randall gets it from Russell
out of a steel or a block bonus that's
thirteen games neither one of those good
feed right there hammered one on that
one
he is the oldest active player the NBA
star go Julius those young legs up and
throwing it down you blindly try to save
it on your defensive end that's trouble
is we get another look at Julius but a
key our B are getting it in transition
where he is really dangerous
Angelo Russell all right positive
reaction as we get another look at
assists being made but the Angela Angela
backing it up Mike talked about his
minutes increasing good luck at home
mazi good good passed out by D'Angelo
pulls up short if you want to go for
Moses Longley there's a system dumped by
Mozgov by eight is the Angeles's I see
you big fella just keep going put it up
you try to flow around the
does that meet gets you in a low sea out
of control here couple acres two on one
tick mark throws it down
bump D'Angelo deep short taken by the
Angela head of the pack is Clarkson he
finds an toxin that's good a leak out
that time by Clarkson and the Lakers
have not enough at 24 you know you would
think they'd be ahead in the game but
they're right where they are tied at 24
it's the three near is D'Angelo Russell
did the task as much as Luke wanigan to
to offensively the other night and Lawal
hits a three ball
he lost sense and they enjoy that get
them going and they get into it is
amazing he loves to have fun
Angela with three threes of his own here
so far he lives in the corner spot it
slow powder goes
[Applause]
three-pointers in a row for the Lakers
caused havoc there see if he's hitting
the outside shot then you can always
close up one the angel' good shoe box
and scores easily night's assists with
Randall the double was about to come
with love Randall's gonna try another
three in there and D'Angelo is going to
pick up the assist team in Steve been
harping on it already the first minute
they are third and points off the
turnovers Jews trying to make it two
buckets here the first couple of minutes
as he's always been a guy that would
catch it and just being very assertive
Tarik Black tonight off the bench the
leading scorer right after he hears D
low to open milks for Tolliver that he
has
[Music]
but don't get a timeout it's a two-point
game but look up at the scoreboard with
427 left and a half but let's get a
couple of new guys on the floor maybe
they'll have some energy coming off the
bench like they did against Orlando man
Russell providing some there collects
the steal and a great look to crab who
gets it to go it's gonna be both tending
anyway present right about the energy
they've provided and there's the pass
from Russell you were talking about the
crab and now Allen that secures the
rebound
Ilia Silva was looking for him the
second time great look for Barroso and
how is Jefferson
what's the fat Carol tosses in from
Mozgov Russell comes to the ball Russell
the bounce Mozgov the flush and a set up
by D'Angelo Russell is that through the
legs again watch this pass through the
legs Meg begin that lovely legs can he
maintain that type of pressure
half-court set here for Brooklyn Russell
goes diagonal on a skip pass Allen
Crabbe sticks in it's a three here's
Russell I speak on Covington kick the
corner Russell trying to shake Kuzma its
web eight points for James Webb the
defensive player nuova Valentine
streaking to the rim levert a factor
Russell perfect feed Joe Harris
two-point game is Livingston got blocked
by Allen here comes Russell in
transition great look to Cunningham who
lays it in to tie this game this first
quarter Russell gives the
hollis-jefferson soaring inside the
bucket of stuff how is Jefferson reading
the defense and him and Russell have
been on point with their connection off
of those ball screens because huh
more activity with the basketball
keep it hop you have been witty and
Russell's good look take a look
rondae hollis-jefferson little cut to
the basket think the legs are okay
that's elite at six nothing Russell -
Allen uncontested Jam it ain't nothing
start low Russell you like that slice
and you love the way this net Siemens
get 52% from the field
Russell directing traffic nice five -
the birthday boy Allen Crabbe
what a pass with the ruffles eyes right
through the gutter the lane through a
cutting trap that was like an outlet
pass and a Miss free throw nice fine to
the corner long two-pointer for Dudley
fouls repeat the lemons Russell to the
corner
Dudley he's got it it's a three he would
have enjoyed it more if he got that win
on the road
nice play out of the timeout as Russell
found Allen anticipating it warriors
it's a four-point game I've look linear
in the early offense and connection that
they have just the hoop there we go
they have missed quite a few in the
paint love her
picks the three on a nice delivery from
Russ is trying to duck to the basket
again so it's Redax job there to pet
bounce the ball just played an extra
second nice decision for Russell Jared
Allen finish it Russell holding off
Gilda's Alexander wise Allison
Jared Allen with seven early points see
the runner there is the eleventh pick
the season and Hanks answer in fact it's
our friend
it's a huge shopper that's the corner
and to your point about what Brett Brown
was saying Philadelphia really struggle
with dribble attack all year Thomas
Jefferson quit City Utah leads at four
to gravity without the ball Mitchell
sticking with him give and go Russell
give it back Jared Allen finishes well
execute the rim ahead Russell
controlling the offense for Brooklyn she
finds Allen with a bullet Allen finishes
in the fed a decent amount of distance
with his passes but doing it with ease
and the pass was a little bit high
intentionally there because sat on skis
coming over he slices it right through
the middle good stuff Michael
caldwell-pope nails the jump shot out of
the timeout
Davis try and stay with them not fall
for a lot of the fakes and he's got some
Russell hits him in-stride dishes for
Russell putting a time on the shot clock
ball handling skills the jam D'Angelo
Russell perfect vision and Atlanta
Motiti out of the rotation
hollis-jefferson it goes down on a
perfect set up by Russell no cleared by
Allen that's to a no against the walls
watch this little cut a top bang he's
done marketing is out of position
defensively its largest lead was nine in
that first half Russell shift the
defender bounces Allen he fakes had
gotten to Blazers in the air for the
open link watch Ray Allen ends up
catching this little bounce pass right
on the basket lay it for him on most
nights slipping to the rim on a pretty
look DeAngelo Russell him what I like
about him and the progression of his
game is just look getting his teammates
going early the play called Russell
speed 29 point of the hands of Miami on
Saturday night Brian Forte
Scott Ford Askia Jason Goldberg the
official hard to the hole in play so
when you run that zone it kind of
confuses the team and a lot of times
causes a turnover well you pay used to
see this in LA all the time but is Chris
Paul two points last shot which looked
like he was going to be on the brink of
missing lob inside what a decision and a
delivery by D'Angelo barnburner going on
here night guys whoo both teams shooting
33% or worse as Davis pounds the rim on
the delivery from Russell he had his
guard down because it fell Urban and
Horford because Boston has a bunch of
guys who believe they should be starters
and they relish these opportunities by
Russell to Davis to talk about a fancy
Toronto has five offensive rebounds and
the Nets lead by one
[Applause]
beautiful look at this venue Russell ops
it caught by Harris he puts it in
D'Angelo Russell with a money dime -
time and that's absolutely picking apart
this Indiana defense what a beautiful
path like the Aaron's a little ruffle
surprised players aren't there together
Jared Allen he's been kind of a
forgotten player in this chili but he
comes up big what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content